We can see from the general form for a complex number, a plus bi, that complex
numbers have both a real part, which comes from the number a, and imaginary
part, which comes from this part bi. Remember a and a are just real numbers
here, but this part bi is an imaginary part, because of the i. And we can talk
about the size of a real number, by plotting it on a simple number line, because
there's just a linear progression of numbers, higher and lower than zero.
Because complex numbers have these two parts though, the real and the imaginary,
we can't plot them in a one dimensional way. Instead, we need to plot them on a
two dimensional axis, similar to the Cartesian Coordinate Plane we've been
working with. This fulfills a very different purpose though. We're not graphing
equations on here, we're not relating variables x and y to one another, we're
just graphing numbers that are written in this form. What we do is we label this
horizontal axis on our plane, the Real axis. And we say that the vertical axis,
is the Imaginary axis. So for any complex number, written in the form a plus bi,
we can instead write it as the point, a comma b, on this coordinate plane. So
the horizontal coordinate, comes from the value of the real part, and the
vertical coordinate comes from the coefficient of the imaginary part. Let's look
at an example. So i plot the point, 4 comma 6, on our set of axis, this
translates into the complex number 4 plus 6i, that's what's being depicted by
this point on this plane. Let's say we want to express negative 7 plus 2i, we go
to negative 7 horizontally, and then up 2. So on this plane, we can graph any
number written in this form.